Speaker 1: This next story is absolutely fascinating.
Many of you might remember the name Sidney
Powell.
Sidney Powell is this kooky lawyer who was,
you know, she was working with Trump on the
election fraud claims.
And then when she got to cartoonish, she was
no longer working with Trump, per the White
House.
But then she was seen at the White House,
and she filed a bunch of these bogus court
legal complaints, all of which were thrown
out.
She is now admitting.
Maybe all that stuff she was saying about
the election was not true.
Now I think we really have to approach this
with a skeptical eye, maybe even a cynical
perspective.
Has she really changed her mind or is she
saying this because she is now in such jeopardy
because of the things that she did?
There's a very interesting vice news article
titled Sidney Powell finally admits that perhaps
the Kraken is not real, but it also says facing
disbarment and several billion dollar lawsuits,
the pro-Trump lawyer is kind of changing her
story, and I think we have to consider the
context here.
The admission from Powell came in a brief
filed Monday to the U.S. Court of Appeal for
the Sixth District.
It was signed by Powell and fellow lawyer
Howard Klein, handler filed on behalf of several
other Kraken lawyers, though notably not pro-Trump
lawyer Lin Wood, who's also a party back in
August.
You might remember and we covered this at
the time, District Court Judge Linda Parker
eviscerated Powell and her team, saying the
lawsuit represents a historic and profound
abuse of the judicial process.
And it does.
It's one thing to take on the charge of vindicating
rights associated with an allegedly fraudulent
election.
It is another to take on the charge of deceiving
a federal court and the American people into
believing rights were infringed without regard
to whether any laws or rights were in fact
violated.
And that is what happened here.
Now, Powell, this is fascinating.
Powell has argued at the time she was under
no obligation to thoroughly research the claims
that she made about voter fraud in the lawsuit.
She sort of made the case at the time.
Listen, people came to me and they said, this
is what happened, and it's not up to me to
independently verify that that's what the
case is.
I'm just the lawyer here, which the judge
does not agree with, and it makes absolutely
no sense.
In this week's filing, Powell and Klein handler
casually admit everything they had been saying
may not actually be true, but because lots
of people were saying it at the time, they
decided to include it.
Quote Millions of Americans believe the central
contentions of the complaint to be true, and
perhaps they are admitting she's no longer
actually confident about the veracity of those
claims.
Now, I think it's important to ask the question
Does she believe all of these wacky election
claims are true?
But she's backing off because of the legal
problems that she's now happening?
She's now having.
Did she never believe the claims were true
or did she believe them, and she has since
changed her mind?
Legally speaking, I don't know that it makes
a difference.
As a reminder, here are some of the wacky
things that this woman said.
Speaker 2: The amount of evidence that this
election was completely fraudulent and that
Joe Biden is a fraudulent president is beyond
overwhelming.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that if we are
to believe her current statement, what she
meant when she said that was the people I'm
working with told me this, but I don't really
know it to be true.
That's what she now says.
Listen, we were told these things.
We didn't independently confirm them.
Here's another Sidney Powell clip.
Speaker 3: So I don't know where to go next,
because this is like something out of a movie.
So the Department of Defense, let's review.
Yeah.
2006 a pattern coming from the Department
of Defense that allows for an algorithm that
can flip and change votes.
The patent was transferred to
Speaker 1: I love the reference to an algorithm.
Now it's an algorithm.
Speaker 2: It can predetermine that algorithm
can predetermine the outcome of an election
and specifically to.
Create a predetermined outcome.
Speaker 1: OK, so maybe she believed that
to be true at the time or again, maybe that's
just what some of the people she was working
with told her.
Here's another one about a secret server.
Speaker 2: What I think really has to be discovered
is that there is a secret server that all
the votes go to where they manipulate the
heck out of it.
Speaker 1: Now, did she believe that at the
time, or was that also just something people
were telling her?
And here's one last one with this wacky guy,
Stu Peters,
Speaker 2: that for at least 20 years now,
somebody other than the voters of the United
States of America has been determining certain
elections, and this year, if not prior years,
it happened to be the presidency of the United
States of America.
Speaker 1: Now, did she believe that at the
time or again, was it just we were told that
stuff and we didn't investigate it.
So Sidney Powell now saying we don't really
know that any of that stuff was true.
It's just what we were told, just what we
were told by plaintiffs.
She's really potentially in trouble here,
and I think that's all that's going on.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show depends on the support
of listeners and viewers like you.
We have a membership program at join Packman
dot com.
We do an extra show every day
for our members and you can use the coupon
code.
Wow.
22 to save big off of the price of a membership
at join Packman dot com.